[موسيقى]
ما الذي يجعل السيارة
مرغوبة للغاية لتكتشف أنني
أركب مع الكثير من الشخصية سيارة نموذجية
لعارضات الأزياء.
وصول موستانج ، أريد أن أذهب في جولة
حيث تعتقد أن حبك
للسيارات الكلاسيكية جاء من ، أعتقد أنني نوعًا
ما قد نشأت كأنني نشأت لأكون الفتاة المسترجلة
كما ربي والدي لأحب أشياء
مثل هذه وما شابه  كنت دائمًا أحب
الدراجات الترابية وسيارات الدفع الرباعي
وأعرف ما إذا كنت دائمًا ما تمارسه ، إنه
أيضًا شيء من لوس أنجلوس أن تكون سيارات محبوبة ،
كل ما تريد أن تفقده
عندما تكون صغيرًا لدي مجموعة صغيرة
في  من الواضح أن منزلي ، ولكن
كما لو كنت أريد حقًا الدخول
إليه والبدء كما رأيتني ، فأنا
أريد شراء هذا الشيء الآن ،
يبدو الأمر كما
لو كان إدمانًا غريبًا إذا أصبح بعض الأشخاص مدمنين على
الوشم  م مثل المدمنين على السيارات
قد يكون كيندال في مواجهة المنزل مباشرة
أفضل حملات الموضة في ld
وبطولة في برنامج تلفزيون الواقع الذي حققته عائلتها ،
لكنها تشعر بالسعادة نفسها للجلوس
خلف عجلة القيادة إذا أحببت ذلك ، فأنا أحب ذلك
كما لو دخلت وأحبني حقًا ،
فأنا أحب أن أحتاج  هذه السيارة
هي سيارة عضلية للغاية ، فهي
تشبه إلى حد كبير الفتاة المسترجلة ، لذا أود أن أحب
هذا وأيضًا تغيرت كل سيارة
أدخلتها في مزاجي مثل كورفيت الخاصة بي
على الرغم من أنها كيندا كلي هي
سيارة عضلية إنها 50 ثانية  السيارة ، لذا فهي
لا تشعر بأنها عضلية ، لذا أشعر بأنني
أنثوية للغاية فيها ، أشعر أنني يجب أن أرتدي ملابس
بطريقة معينة وكأننا
نظارات شمسية مجنحة للغاية ومثلما تعلمون ، أعني أن
هناك فقط لا أعرف كيف تفعل  هذا
الحشد الذي تشعر أن هذا يجعلني
أشعر بالراحة كفتاة رائعة ، شكرًا لك
على الرحلة البحرية اليوم ، لماذا أنا متحمس
لرؤية المزيد من السيارات ، نعم لدي المكان الذي يمكنني
أن أريكم فيه تعال ، فلنضربها ونفعلها
[موسيقى]
مرحباً ، مرحباً ، جيد أن تكون هنا
Derek ، من الجيد مقابلتك.
أنا من أرقى
السيارات الكلاسيكية التي ستجدها في العالم هنا في
لوس أنجلوس
[موسيقى] ،
لذا ، ستة ملايين دولار لهذا ،
هل جربته في الباب ، فهي
بحاجة إلى السرعة بشدة ، ما هي
أغلى سيارة نستطيع؟  شاهد اليوم
أغلى سيارة في الغرفة اليوم في
سيارة فيراري موديل 1958 بقاعدة عجلات طويلة بوزن 250 جرامًا في
كاليفورنيا ، وهذا هو الاسم الكامل
الذي نقدره لتلك السيارة من عشرة إلى اثني عشر
مليون دولار ، إنها واحدة من أكثر سيارات
فيراري شهرة على الإطلاق.
ما
تلمسه كل شيء عنه جميل جدًا ،
مثل عجلات القيادة المذهلة ، سأضع قاربًا